miss radler are there any other people
observers outside
that want to come in all right if you're
here i'm going to ask everyone to remain
throughout the testimony if we get a
break in the witness you can get up and
leave but we i i have heard some
complaints made by the jurors that
they're distracted at points because of
people walking in and out of the
courtroom
so if you're here just remain here we
don't have too much longer today just
remain here you have to go somewhere
um at four o'clock or something then i'm
going to ask you either to stay or leave
now i don't want the jurors being
disturbed by people walking in and out
all the time thank you
and miss ridley can you just check
outside if there are anyone else that
wants to come in they need to come in
now otherwise they're not coming in
is
thank you
let's keep it
might be seated represent a jury
members of the jury my staff did inform
me at the break that there were a couple
complaints about people walking in and
out of the courtroom during testimony
and the door slamming i've spoken to the
people in the courtroom now and told
them they have to wait until a break in
the witness testimony
and my staff has also checked out in the
hallway to make sure that people who
wanted to come in and see the testimony
are already in here and hopefully we'll
keep that at a minimum
if it happens again i'll see it i i'm
sorry i missed it before but now that
i'm attuned to it i'm going to look for
it so if people start walking in and out
i'll take corrective action
sorry for the disturbance
all right um mr vitale's on the stand
we'll continue with examination go ahead
mr
mr
bolinkos
i'm going to show you these photographs
[Music]
first 852
does
that photograph accurately depict
the injuries to michael barissone's face
area yes
855
does that
photograph accurately depict
the injuries to the left side of
michael's fa michael barrason's face
yes
864 does this accurately defect the
injuries to the right side of his face
yes age 66 does that accurately reflect
uh the injuries to the
his left side
yes it does
and when you were examining him he
didn't have a shirt on correct
i don't believe he had a shirt on now
and 8
56
does that accurately depict
his left arm and the injury that he
suffered
you can't really see much there since
it's bandaged up but he did have
injuries to his left arm so i would
assume that's probably okay now
with regards to his injuries did you uh
document
your initial physical findings
yes
on the patient care report
and and with regards to uh
the head area what was your findings
can i refer back to the if you needed to
read the questions
has that document been marked mr
blinkist
can you just for the record in mind
600-5
thank you 600-5 is what the witness is
referring to
judge i don't have an objection to the
witness referring to that as long as the
record's clear about whether he's
testifying from his memory or from what
was documented
i think he's refreshing his recollection
now yeah yes okay
so
what what were your observations
in your physical findings regarding uh
the head area
abrasions hematomas
what's a hematoma uh it's a bruising to
the face
yeah he had lacerations and uh
that were also on his face on all sides
too so how about his uh the face what
what did you observe on his face uh
those injuries that i just mentioned
were
on all sides of his face
his face and the left side of his head
as far and the right side of his head as
well
did you notice any injuries to
both of his ears
not specifically
do those photographs that you've
reviewed
refresh your recollection with regards
to injuries of the years yes it looks
consistent
how about his
general back area what did you observe
there
and you can refresh your report if you
need to yeah i'll have to just look
again because uh go ahead
again for the record he's referring
with regards to his back area what did
you note
one second
uh on here i have noted that his back uh
examination appeared to be normal
uh there were there were some abrasions
otherwise normal
about the left arm
upper arm uh the left upper arm if i
could just
refresh my memory here
looks like um
his left upper arm did have uh
abrasions still
punctures
and was uh
was there any blood that you noticed
um it's not on here but i remember that
there was dry blood on there from the
abrasions and puncture wounds right how
about the right upper arm
still uh abrasions on here
right there for our abrasions yeah
version some controlled bleeding okay uh
what did you notice about his left
forearm
um his left forearm
uh i do remember it was kind of weak he
was in handcuffs
but it seemed like that arm was uh
like weak difficult for him to move
compared to the other upper extremity
and did you notice any deformities in
that arm
uh
i don't specifically remember a
deformity to it but he was also in
handcuffs so his arm was already a
little
in an awkward position
did you make any reference in your
report with regards to the left forearm
findings
uh yeah with uh the motor function being
abnormal slash weakness to me that was
his him moving that left arm seemed
decreased
did you notice any puncture wounds on
the left arm
uh he
yes we did have that side of his body
head puncture once yep
how about his left
upper leg area
his left upper leg area was bandaged
prior to my arrival so i couldn't do
much of an exam on it and did you
receive information with regards to uh
who bandaged it and for what
i object to for what judge
for the reasons stated
overwhelmed i'll allow it
um as far as who bandaged it i don't
remember who bandaged the the injury
what was the bandage for
um
on this
yeah the for the dog bite
did you find any
any other puncture wounds on his body
left upper extremity
and the left shoulder i believe
how about his right eye
the right eye findings uh saying that
there was a laceration there which was
consistent with the rest of the
head assessment that we did prior
and what did you note based on your
observations was his uh
mental status
confused altered mental status
and did you put that in your official
report yes
it should be right on this page here
which at this time i would move into
evidence 852
55
64
66
and 56.
all right 8 52
55 56 64 and 66 will be moved into
evidence the court and council
previously
addressed any objections to those
photographs those were allowed in by the
court okay judge my email doesn't seem
to be working i'd like to just publish
him sure
go ahead
while mr golinkas is doing that i'll
just put on the record he's going to
determine the day when photo 66 was
taken it was not taken on the day of the
incident
he doesn't have that right now but he is
going to get it for the record
all right thank you
now now i'll display 55.
mr bilinkas are you going to walk back
and forth
five separate times
i don't know any other way to do it just
hand your number one the stack of
photographs they can pass it down and
then when during number seven is done
you can take it and pass it to the
jurors just have them pass it away
just give him the whole stack let him
review it and then he can pass it on
all right mr blinkers you want to hand
those uh to juror number eight please
so
so
all right the jurors have viewed all of
the photographs
please uh proceed mr blinkus no further
questions
mr horn cross-examination thank you
honor mr vitale you
s
traveled in the ambulance with a
defendant and another
partner yes what was her name kimberly
held and did
patrol officer hensley ride in the
ambulance with the world yes
now you indicated that mr barrisone was
alert and conscious during the transport
yes
he was alert to person
person and place and place
and you didn't note any neurological
deficits
no other than his confusion
his speech was normal yes
and you indicated that he made some
statements during the course of the
transport
yes
he indicated
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids
yes
did he also staging you read the entire
passage
left some now
was there something left out mr
shellhorn there are other comments in
there judge i just want to focus on that
part of it he left out
hold on don't say well let me see that
side more
and that's uh 605 for the record your
honor
does that indicate in quotation marks
someone drove down my driveway and said
she was going to take my kids that's all
i remember
yes
and was that put putting quotation marks
because it was a direct quote it was
did the defendant also report that his
heart was hurting but not physically
that was also quoted yes
meaning that it was putting quotes into
the report because that was the exact
words that he used correct thank you mr
vitale no further questions judgment
right
you may step down sir thank you
do you have another witness mr blancas
yes george kimberly health
what kimberly
helm
h-e-l-d
held okay kimberly hill
hi miss held how are you good afternoon
good uh please remain standing for a
minute uh place your left hand on the
bible on the witness stand please raise
your right hand my court clerk will
administer an oath
in the presence of almighty god that the
testimony gives to this court regarding
this matter shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth speaking
please state your name your last name
for the record kimberly health h-e-l-d
thank you oh you may have a seat man
please keep your voice up nice and loud
that microphone only records it does not
project your voice into coordinates all
right very good if you don't understand
the question please indicate that to me
and i'll have counsel rephrase the
question very good mr blancas direct
examination
uh miss hill um
directing your attention to uh august 7
2019
uh where were you employed saint claire
shells
in what capacity a paramedic
and what training if any did you have as
a paramedic to
obtain that position i received an
associate's degree in paramedicine
science at bergen community college
and how long have you been working for
saint players uh up to that point a
little short of two years
okay i'm going to direct your attention
to august
7th 2019
did you have an occasion to respond to
uh
uh
4-1-1 west mill road yes
and was that michael barrasson's uh song
do you know
and why did you respond there
we were dispatched by our communications
and
um
upon arrival
at any point in time did you have an
opportunity to see
my client michael barrison yes
did you treat him my partner treated him
and were you there observing correct
and
can you tell me uh
what his uh mental status was when uh
you were treating him
upon our assessment he was altered and
confused
in doing your assessment did you ask him
specific questions as to
what he what had happened on that day
yes
and what did he indicate to you in
response to those questions may i refer
to my report
all right let's have that mark please
that's your own copy man
just for the record we need to mark a
copy my apologies no no no no apology
necessary
just make sure that's the same document
that you have
d600-5
okay
can you rephrase the question
sure what would uh
what if anything do you recall michael
barrissone saying when you asked him
what had happened on that day
so per the report
do you i
apologize someone drove down my driveway
and said
she was going to take my kids that's all
i remember and quote
was he able to
just describe or tell you any events
that occurred on that day when asked
nothing
else did he say anything about his heart
yes there's a quote saying my heart
hurts but not physically unquote
did you have an opportunity to uh
observe the injuries uh on michael
barrasso correct there's a in a detailed
reporting of his injuries on the report
can i show you d
856
[Music]
did he have an injury of his left arm
that you observed it was reported here
that
she has left upper arm findings pd
reporter docked by upon left upper
my apologies that's the thigh peter
reporter left forearm has deformity ice
pack and splint was applied prior to als
arrival multiple abrasions and punctured
wounds to the left arm how about his
left side his torso area
okay
irrespective of what's in your in your
report did you observe
these injuries to his left side at any
point in time while you were treating
him not to my reflections okay
i'm sorry i didn't catch that answer
that's my reflection okay just make sure
you keep your voice up man because our
jurors in the galleries have to hear
how about d
864.
did you observe injuries
head findings or multiple hematomas on
both sides of his head and does that
photograph factor we depict those
injuries
yes
how about 855
on this side of his face bruising noted
on the side of the base of left ear with
blood
and how about 852
the injuries uh on his face correct
version noted
now at some point in time
did you
have a impression
slash diagnosis based on your treatment
as paramedics we do not diagnose we
treat what we see and we were assessing
for the altered mental status okay and
what was your impression
he remained altered although we've ruled
out hypoglycemia via glucometer
i have nothing for you
cross-examination
you need this report here council
uh ms held you don't know specifically
when the defendant said someone drove
down my driveway and said she was gonna
take my kids that's all i remember you
don't know if that's true
yeah you don't know if he did remember
or didn't remember that's what we were
told
no further questions judge thank you
all right you may step down miss hell
thank you
do you have another witness this
afternoon mr blinkist
sure
defense calls
dr joseph a haney
what dr joseph haney please
hi doctor
good afternoon please remain standing
for a minute you need to be sworn so uh
left hand on the bible raise your right
hand my core clerk will administer a
note
do you swing the presence of almighty
god that the testimony gives to this
court regarding this matter shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth
yes please state your name as well your
last name for the record joseph heaney
h-e-i-n-e-y
thank you my doctor you may have a seat
please keep your voice up microphone uh
does not project it only records so okay
we have to hear your natural voice in
the courtroom
if you don't understand the question
please don't answer it just indicate to
the court you're not sure you don't
understand and i'll have to counsel
rephrase all right go ahead mr balinkas
doctor where are you employed
currently i'm employed at um new york
presbyterian brooklyn methodist hospital
um directing your attention back to
august of 2019 where were you employed
at morristown medical center
in what capacity
um i was an emergency physician in
training resident physician
on the trauma service
that day okay and uh
can you give the jury a little bit of
your background in regards to your
training
um
so
i actually just completed training
within the last year three-year
residency in emergency medicine
you know before that was in medical
school um graduated school in 2018
graduated residency in 2021.
where did you go to school
new york medical college
new york all right directing your
attention to august 7
2019
did
you have an opportunity to treat michael
barrasson
i did
that was that morristown medical center
correct
and and did you do an assessment uh
uh
for your evaluation
yes what what physical uh
observations did you make of any
injuries to michael barrasso
start off the bat we noted that i
believe his left elbow was deformed um
we could see that pretty clearly as he
came in um
as we
did sort of our heads to assessment and
speaking to him
um
i i noticed there was the possibility of
blood behind his left eardrum it was it
was unclear it had that appearance
which worried us for a potential head
injury
and otherwise
otherwise as noted in the chart in terms
of physical injuries i don't recall much
else
i assume you've
seen a lot of people uh since then
correct
i'm going to show you
what's been marked into evidence
852 does that accurately depict the
injuries that you saw on michael
barrasson's face
yes that that seems correct
how about my memory 855 does that
also act early to pick the injuries
yes
and is that left ear the one you're
referring to
yes
864
it seems correct
these are injuries to his
left side did you notice any injuries to
the left side of his body
uh if not if otherwise as i stated as
noted in the chart um i don't recall at
the top of my head
how how about 856 is
is that the uh
left arm that
you refer to as being deformed when you
first observed him yes
and
what was done to that left arm
so initially um we established that he
had good blood flow
past the injury of the elbow a good
pulse
we were still concerned for a
significant injury possibly to other
structures like nerves we attempted to
we obtained an x-ray and determined it
was dislocated
after which we attempted to reduce the
dislocation we did administer
a sedative medication to do that we're
initially not successful
and out of concern for
the potential head injury and other
injuries
and the fact that the arm still had
circulation we elected to bring him to
a ct scan to further assess for other
injuries and eventually once
we were able to establish everything
with this ct scan we're able to
relocate the arm with help of our
orthopedic colleagues right now
did you make note of his mental status
yes
and what was that
well when he came in he was responsive
he was answering my questions
um
to a degree in obeying simple commands
one of the important things we assessed
for things like squeeze my hand look
over here doing simple things like that
i did ask if he remembered the
you know what had happened uh prior to
arrival and he told me he didn't
remember
um
and
that was that's what i recall
was he in a altered mental state
at any point
um
i'd say yes that's a bit that's a broad
term at the time we were
considering that that he was or
whether there was a physical or a
psychological component or both but yes
overall
nothing further
cross-examination
doctor uh
do you still have that
chart in front of you
uh no
um i'm sorry is this
no i don't think i don't i think that
was some previous witness you have this
witnesses chart
thank you let me use my judge
just directing your attention at the
bottom right hand corner
and i'm not sure what that's marked i
apologize
uh but it should say on the blue uh the
blue sticker at the top what's that
number
this one is d20 d20
doctor on the i'm not sure which page it
is in front of you but it on mine it
shows up at page eight okay in the
bottom right hand corner
um
i'm not seeing anything on
mr horn why don't you want to show them
where you want to refer them to please
that's my pj pg
so i'm going to direct you right here to
uh
up here
the question about the
no acute intracranial hemorrhage or
significant mass effect can you explain
what that means to the jury
right so that was uh as i stated we
perform ct scans um
of his brain and other areas that's
referring to the scan of the brain
one of the things the first thing we
look for is bleeding within the skull
either around the brain within the brain
and the read from the radiologist states
there's no um
bleeding or intracranial hemorrhage
there's no bleeding within the brain or
around the brain within the skull
uh or other
incidental findings such as the tumor
which would cause a mass effect so
there's nothing uh grossly abnormal
about within the skull thank you very
much doctor no further questions josh
any follow-up no all right you may step
down doctor thank you very much for
coming to court
all right we'll break it's uh 4 4 20 or
so
so members of the jury we're going to uh
break recess for the evening please
don't discuss the case with anyone we'll
see you tomorrow morning same time
we'll get going as close to nine o'clock
as we can so please get here around 8
30. thank you
[Music]
because you
up there
[Music]
all right mr blick is who's on for
tomorrow